now the problem is I don't really blame
Our Generation for it because if you're
born to a single mother home or a single
father home but like let's be honest
single mother home I think I saw a staff
at 80 of kids nowadays are born into
single parent households
eighty percent so if you're one of the
80 of people that was born into a single
parent home
and you have no siblings who else are
you gonna go to for a dicey advice you
you have your mother and if your mother
is crazy then you have no options you
have to go to strangers so that's
internet therapists coaches teachers so
now you're getting strangers involved in
a family affair